well we had an absolutely Blockbuster
jobs report last week we have
essentially full employment in the
United States we are down to 3.5 percent
unemployment and I have video for you of
Fox news reporter Maria Bartiromo
praising the jobs report and it looks
like a hostage video we are going to get
to that in a moment first the numbers
U.S job growth unexpectedly soars in
July the unemployment gains far
surpassed expectations show the labor
market is not slowing despite efforts by
the Federal Reserve to cool the economy
the U.S employers added 528
000 jobs in July the expectation was
roughly half of that this brings the
total employment level back to its
February 2020 level remember the right
loves to say labor force participation
rate well we are now back to February
2020 remember that was Trump at the time
participation rate the unemployment rate
is 3.5 percent matching the 50-year low
we have a 50-year record low
unemployment rate at this point in time
the expectation was for 250 000 new jobs
in July 528
000 were created now what are the
counter claims from the American right
wing one of them is but some people
still lost their jobs in July yes this
happens every month you have job
creation and you have people who lose
jobs and then you have the net did you
create more jobs than were lost or not
people are losing jobs all the time the
number of jobs lost in July was Tiny
secondly well what about wages well
wages are up as well
third what does Joe Biden have to do
with this okay you guys are already
familiar with that one so here's Maria
Bartiromo she has a business show she
can't really ignore the story and this
just feels like a hostage video there's
this famous video of I believe it was a
Vietnam pow who was filmed saying how
well he was being treated but with his
eyes he was blinking Morse code for
torture this seems like another one of
these hostage videos take a look at this
this is Fox News and Maria Bartiromo
visibly pained by having to accept
the job Market's looking really good
headline here this is a blockbuster
report this is much higher than anybody
was expecting 528
000 jobs created in the month of July is
more than double the expectations which
calls for job growth of 250 000. all
areas of the economy actually saw job
growth including Leisure Hospitality the
services industry the industrial
industry that's all good news the bad
news but uh oh how are these jobs bad
for Joe Biden this ensures that we are
going to see a Federal Reserve that
stays as aggressive as ever the markets
right now are now that's not really bad
news okay the the point is the Federal
Reserve reacts to what's happening in
the economy she's sort of saying like
the economy is so good that the Federal
Reserve is going to have to keep doing
the things they do when the economy is
good pricing in a 65 chance that the
Federal Reserve raises interest rates
and by the way if they're already
pricing it in
it's all okay Maria let's relax another
75 basis points in the next meeting
which is in September we are waiting for
the Jackson Hole event which is where
Federal Reserve officials gather that
will be newsworthy in the coming weeks
to find out how the FED will deal with a
jobs Market all right so it's funny she
uses a tone that expresses significant
concern but it's a genuinely fantastic
jobs report now the economy still has
all the problems that it always has we
still have high inflation uh we still
have inequality we still have people who
have to work multiple we have all those
things but these are the standard
metrics we use and have used for at
least 50 years uh now what will they do
tomorrow when the new inflation report
for July shows an inflation decline
that's my expectation for uh tomorrow or
Wednesday I forget which day the
inflation report's coming out how will
they spin that as bad for Joe Biden you
know they will